welcome back to New rockstars I'm Eric
Boss and deleted storylines from Ant-Man
and the WASP quantumania would have
given us some further context to what
exactly was happening in that
probability storm and would have trapped
another Avenger in a multiversal crisis
very similar to that of the Scarlet
Witch stop it okay okay sorry Wanda
nothing compares to you nothing compares
spoiler warning ahead for quantumania
who Van Dyne or one of her probabilities
storm doppelgangers was going to have
children but this was removed from the
film having a hypothetical life choice
variant still working at Baskin Robbins
is one thing but having one raising a
family is a very different life path
several steps removed from where hope
has been their life so far with
hauntingly deep implications for what
exactly characters in a probability
storm are going through and how
connected this setting is to the actual
Multiverse in the Marvel Cinematic
Universe going forward a reminder to
subscribe to our new channel the Deep
dive and the best way to support the
Deep dive is with some of our deep dive
specific merch like this last but not
deep dive shirt or this really warm
Beady all this stuff you can get at nerd
Riot that shot so in the wake of
quantumania as the discourse has begun
to focus on the post-production process
and the VFX work on the film vulture
interviewed a few bfx workers who
anonymously revealed that much of what
we see in the latter third and fourth of
the film was actually the result of a
lot of scrambling much of these scenes
had to be reworked with cutting scenes
rolling Shots by moving a shot a few
frames around in a cut and just
generally altering scenes to get it all
done on time so if things seem to be a
little chaotic in the second half of
this film that would be why like I
pointed out an example of this before
the scene where Kang explains to Janet
Van Dyne his bitter history with the
Kang Dynasty while he projects the two
timeline rings around the room this
scene cuts off abruptly in what seems
like the middle of a conversation as if
we were going to cut back to it but we
never did and there was a similar moment
a few scenes earlier during the
probability storm sequence now if you
can't tell from watching this channel I
love big Blockbuster experiences but
since I don't live in a movie theater I
gotta find an easier way to get that
same rush and that's where raid Shadow
Legends comes in I love how epic it
feels every time I play raid is AAA
gaming experience that fits in your
pocket and if Valentine's Day got you in
the mood for love rave's got that
covered too my top three rage ships have
got to be rotos and sippy Seducer and
temptress and astralon and count as
licks I don't care if I can't see their
eyes I know they're burning with passion
right now new players can do the raid
Love quest just download Rave using our
link copy your in-game player ID and
then enter it in at
raidlovequest.plerium.com go before
March 14th and play one of the
Valentine's themed mini-games for a
chance to win some fantastic in-game and
real-life prizes including Valentine's
Day themed raid Champions and even
Amazon gift cards worth up to a thousand
dollars if you're an old raid player you
can still share the love too use the
promo code Saint valentine23 to get a
small Valentine's gift from us to you
and what we personally like there's
always a ton of cool events there's
Forge past season seven this month and
different events as part of the three
month long fourth anniversary Titan
event and more if you haven't started
playing raid yet click the link in the
description or scan our QR code to get
unique 35 worth of bonuses including the
free epic champion yotin and several
other useful stuff all your rewards will
be waiting for you right here so thanks
again to raid for sponsoring this video
Scott scrambles alongside His Thousand
other possibilities and climbs atop them
to reach the rings of the multiversal
engine core but false meanwhile hope
dives into that storm too and there's a
brief moment where she interacts with
some of her possibilities one says get
out of the way another snaps at her what
are you doing in Our Hope radios back to
Janet asking a mom and Janet radios back
don't look at them they're just
possibilities they're not you which we
have to pause here and ask how does
Janet know this Janet at some point in
the past must have tried to explore
inside of this expanded core got cut in
her own probability storm and it freaked
her the out too now in this scene
we don't really see hope again until she
swoops down to grab Scott and both
swarms of Scott and of Hope condensed
down into one of each but based on Hope
buddy and heads with her other
possibilities it definitely seemed like
something more was going to come from
this and lo and behold we just learned
of a legitimate deleted scene from the
sequence that would have given us more
of Hope's variant life paths an
Instagram post by the mother of a child
actor named Lucas Grant showed us a
series of photos of this boy on set with
Evangeline Lilly and Peyton Reed the
caption claiming that the storyline was
changed and his scenes did not make it
into the final version of the movie the
photo show Evangeline Lily with longer
hair wearing domestic clothes alongside
this boy and holding another girl on her
hip this is a blue screen set and given
what we know about Hope throughout this
movie the most likely place in
quantumania where this makes sense is
inside of the probability storm a
glimpse of an alternate life of Hope Van
Dyne who knows could have been an
alternate ending now that it looks like
Scott's timeline was changed maybe hope
ended up in a changed timeline as well
with kids because this movie's First Act
makes a big point of showing hope as a
career-oriented woman running the pin
Van Dyne Foundation winning awards for
her humanitarian efforts with a new
shorter haircut this domestic hope looks
like a variant light path that hope
would have seen in the probability storm
the equivalent to Scott running into his
Baskin Rob himself the big difference is
the Scott that we know had previously
worked at Baskin Robbins in his current
historical timeline but hope never had
kids this light path would have been a
Nexus Point Way further back in her life
and based on the age of these kids they
are old enough that Scott Lang could
have been the father and yes this may
remind you of Wanda maximoff in the MCU
from Wata Vision to Doctor Strange in
the Multiverse of Madness dream walking
into other realities in which she is a
mother to two kids it's also what
Kingpin experiences in the animated
Spider-Man into the spider-verse
building a collider device to connect
with a universe where his wife Vanessa
and his son are still alive this deleted
scene tells us that the filmmakers
Marvel Studios originally intended the
probability storms to have much deeper
implications for these characters inner
psychologies and for how the Multiverse
will function going forward this is
something I talked about in my deep dive
into everything everywhere all at once
which you should check out by
subscribing to our other channel the
Deep dive that movie works so well by
grounding the Multiverse which is really
an abstract concept to a lot of people
grounding it inside of the wistful
imagination of a single day dreamer life
path's not taken something we all
understand Multiverse mad is starting to
get into that with Wanda dreaming of
Westview but very quickly got away from
it the animated what if series did a
great job exploring that in the episode
4 Doctor Strange episode now the
probabilities storm in quantumania seems
like a hypothetical thought experiment
the possibilities that Scott and hope C
reflected back to them in their mind's
eyes messing with their heads like Luke
in the cave and Dagobah and The Empire
Strikes Back but the reason this
phenomenon is happening is that they are
inside of a broken multiversal engine
core a mysterious and unique piece of
technology created by Kang that allows
him to navigate all of space and time
for that to even be possible this device
must have some actual link to the
Baseline tapestry of the Multiverse a
Quantum state in which subatomic
particles like the cat in Schrodinger's
Box can exist in multiple States at once
Bill Foster described this phenomenon in
the 2018 Hitman the WASP film the object
in question would be both in and out of
phase with multiple parallel realities
so I don't think this is just in their
heads it definitely is but also very
very real and what we are seeing here in
the probability storm is the Quantum
scientific description of what Sorcerers
call dreamwalking in the MCU incursions
on a very small individual scale chaotic
messy and extremely personal and
therefore every time Kang uses this
device to neuro kinetically travel the
Multiverse he is bypassing the mess of
this process to pinball around the
variant universes to the precise one he
wants to go to but that trip requires
Kang to see every tragic ultimate life
path of its own and somehow come out of
that feeling nothing remember Dr Strange
would do something similar in Avengers
Infinity War where he looked at 14
million 605 different Futures that is
something Kang goes through every time
he travels so when Kang snaps at Janet
you have no idea what I have lost could
what he lost refer to similar families
and children who call out to him for
help the same way the Scarlet Witch's
boys did to her in the one division post
credit scene
hey another reminder to subscribe to our
new channel the Deep dive where I'm
actually gonna have a deeper analysis of
quantumania coming Friday February 24th
you can follow me on Instagram and
Twitter at a boss following new
rockstars And subscribe to new rockstars
for more analysis of everything you'd
love thanks for watching bye
[Music]
foreign